the challenge with entrepreneurship is
survivorship and let me explain to what
I mean by this generally when a person
goes from being an employee to deciding
to start their own business and you want
to be an entrepreneur you generally have
a two-year window it's what you have of
surviving because the first two years
anything that can go wrong as a
brand-spankin'-new entrepreneur it's
generally going to go wrong and I think
the biggest problem that you have the
first two years is the fact that when
you're an employee you do and there is
certain things that are told here's what
I need you to do and you do it so what
muscle stops working is the creative
muscle stops working and the muscle that
needs to be working for a person to make
it in business is that same creative
muscles that's been sleeping for many
many years so let's talk about what I
mean here with you today let me give you
study let me give you study George land
who was a did a lot of researchers in
his career dr. George land did a study
many many years ago in 1968 that he took
1600 kids he took 1600 kids ranging 3 to
5 years old to do creativity tests 1600
kids to see what type of score they'll
get and eventually that same creativity
test was so good that NASA ended up
using it to find the innovative
scientists and engineers so watch what
happens here at the age of five years
old these kids he did a study on their
creativity test they scored 98 percent
now stay with me here ninety-eight
percent then he took the same kids five
years later at 10 years old study on
them
it went from 98% what do you think it
went to 5 years later from 5 years old
to 10 years well from 98% to 30% the
creativity test dropped from 98 to 30%
then at 15 years old that 30% goes to
12% then at an adult 280,000 people that
he tested on 280,000 people he tested on
that creativity test ends up being 2% at
30 years old and what he concluded at
the end is that non-creative behavior is
learned we are all born creative but our
non behave
your non creative behavior we learn
isn't that strange because most of them
who yell learn how to be creative you
gotta learn how to be did it you've been
creative all your life you just stop
being creative we're born creative the
other night I'm watching my kids my
two-year-old my my four year old they
have this card they're playing with a
polar back we won't because they pull it
back home it goes they pull up my palm
it goes eventually goes on one of the
couches and then go down to reach it and
it can reach it so I'm just am not
helping them I'm just sitting to see
what they're going to do then they go
down and they go to the back and they
grab the butter knife and they try to
pull it out with the butter knife
nothing's happening then they go back
and they bring another you know the
salad would he call it what he called
the salad anyways they take ten and they
try to bring it out and it's not working
out then they go grab the broom and then
finally they brought the car out and
they got a couple balls and marbles and
all this other stuff out but that was
their way of saying I'm a two-year-old
I'm gonna figure out a way of getting
this thing out here and a lot of times
we become adults and all we need to do
is go get a broom to pull the car out to
save our financial problems and we don't
do it because we've been taught these
non-creative behaviors so what does this
have to do with business I think it has
everything to do with business because
when you think about business when you
think about business almost anybody that
I see who makes it as an entrepreneur
you learn about them in boardrooms and
in rooms where we're thinking about
ideas and I'll ask questions and you'll
say oh that guy's still this that guy's
still this but you'll generally say what
if we did this this this this this boom
good for you what if we did that thought
that I'm thinking about do not did you
think about doing this this is did you
think I'm doing that because a lot of
times people come to me and they'll say
you know I don't know how to handle this
problem my company and we'll sit down
have a 5-10 minute conversation and walk
away and how come out I know that before
it's because they're learned a non
creative behavior that's prevented them
from processing issues and solving
problems at higher levels of their
business which has caused them to not
make it in business and fail and it can
be learned so let's talk about a few
different things your first thing I want
to talk to you about is this eight
things that causes entrepreneurs to be
more creative and some people may say
well this has to do with all of us
period but I'm going to use this a
for entrepreneurs mainly number one is
desperation what is desperation you have
no idea how much we are reminded of our
creativity when we're desperate you have
no idea how much we find out about our
creativity when we're desperate
surviving surviving if you have to
figure out a way to survive when you're
desperate you're going to figure out a
way to survive yesterday I was sitting
out with Mario and I told Mario I said
Mario let me ask you a question I said
let's just say you lost this job company
went out of business your wife left you
your kids left you have no apartment we
have no car your license is suspended
you have no money to go back anywhere no
one who is willing to have you live with
them what are you going to do today
right now go look what he does he sister
he goes oh so I don't have place to live
no friends gonna let you live with them
I don't have a car to sleep in you don't
have a car to sleep in um well if I go
get a job and I need to eat food today I
will not be able to get paid for two
weeks if I've w-2 because I have no
savings so I need to get something that
makes money today maybe I need to go
work somewhere where there's tip and I
can get something today or go to person
that selling products and I can take
that product and go sell it out that's
cash and I can make some immediate money
today and I can buy something wholesale
and I can sell it at retail but by the
tummy was done after 10 minutes
he figured out his one two three and he
said this is what I would do now why did
he come out with the one two three
because the mind went into a place of
desperation when we're desperate we
figure out things to survive but the
challenge becomes this the purpose of
entrepreneurship is not just survival
you're not supposed to just survive I
see a lot I've been a business owner for
thirty years man it's a struggle it's
not supposed to be a struggle for 30
years it's not supposed to be I've been
an entrepreneur for 15 years you know
what it is man it's a grind and I'm
grinding I'm just like oh my gosh no
it's not supposed to be that way
you've chosen to to be in the
survivorship surviving mindset surviving
is a mindset you got eventually graduate
you got to graduate this mindset into
creation but desperation too often we
let too
any instances get too dependent we're
too desperate and guess what most of the
time it's already too late
company goes out of business or your
business goes out you have to close up
shop or you give up and go back and do
whatever else you have to do point
number two is frustration creativity is
also caused by being frustrated I'm so
frustrated what's happening my kids
I can't believe my kids are behaving
this way you know what what do I need to
do number ten times we need to do this
this this we need to move we need to
have what if we did this and what do we
have that he needs to hang out with this
game so we need to move over here we
need to get this out sonic private
school but other then you come out with
three steps you're frustrating I'm so
frosted my financial situation and my I
can't even tell you I need to figure out
a way to make more money and what if I
start doing this and if I start doing
that and the business and I talk to that
get that that boom frustration you know
my business isn't grown at the rate I
wanted to grow so sick and tired the
other guy came here before me after me
he's only been a business owner for two
years I've been a business owner for
eight years how's that he's making six
hundred thousand dollars a year and I'm
only making seventy two thousand dollars
you there's nothing more different about
him I need to change something about my
business frustration causes a certain
creativity to you number three curiosity
curiosity can either be a muscle or it
can be a byproduct let me explain what I
mean by this it can either be the fact
that you're very very curious human
being you're absolutely curious all the
time or it could be the fact that it's a
muscle you're developing you're
developing this muscle it's it's it's
it's um you know I'm so curious to know
whether we can do that what if we can do
this thing better I'm so curious that
what if we can go faster I'm so curious
what if we can make this thing to be
cleaner I'm so curious what if we can
make this thing to have the product that
when you eat the sandwich it's better
I'm so curious what if we could do this
this that curiosity creates creativity
number four love when you love something
when you love somebody you're creative
when you love somebody you give them
gifts in a creative way and you go to
their house and and you know you'll put
a card then they'll open up the card and
when they open up the card and it says I
love you so much baby that you know my
lives change ever since I started dating
you and ba-ba-ba-ba-bom I want you to go
to your bedroom and see what's under
your pillow and she goes to her bedroom
and goes under the pillow and it under
the pillow is a nice little gift and
let's just say she loves starbursts you
know
can and there's a box of starburst candy
there and then with a note I know you
love starbursts I just want to do
whatever I can every time you put a
smile on your face it puts a smile on my
face but there's another one I want you
to go to your car right now and open up
the dashboard and she goes and opens up
the dashboard and the dashboard opens up
and boom next thing you know there's a
gift card too
you know a spotter she wants to go to I
know how much you love to go to the spa
today's your day I want to pamper you
you have an appointment set up today at
2 o'clock
but there's more I want you to go right
now to the closet and open up your
closet and your favorite dress there's
something hanging off the top of the
coat hanger so she goes it let's create
a hell of so I wanted to it's creative
things you don't suck oh my gosh babe I
love you so because you'll love we were
creative the other part number five is
hate when they hate somebody you're also
very creative you said you know what let
me tell you what he did to me you know
what I'm gonna do I want to do this and
I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna put this
together and then we going to get soon
then we're going to get them like this I
mean that's not good creativity but it's
still creativity the other one is
passionate when you're passionate about
something you have many ways of being
creative many many ways are being
created it doesn't matter what it is if
you're passionate about something you're
doing that gives birth to creativity
then its purpose if it's a bigger cause
bigger reason to want it to do something
bigger you know somebody asked me
yesterday I'm working on a very very big
project that has to do with some people
around the world that are very very
well-known celebrities I launched it to
here pretty soon when it's finalized and
we had seven main camera crew who flew
in to meet with me and we recorded we
shot the whole thing and they were
asking so why do you create all this
content you know about entrepreneurship
why are you doing this I said honestly
this is an absolute purpose of mine it
has got nothing to do with money money
is very easy to make very very easy to
make once you learn how to make money
one time you can learn how to make money
for the rest of your life I said but
there's a purpose where I know what it
did for me to go from a 1.8 GPA kid in a
broken up family when I joined the
military because I don't have any other
route to coming out and you know I
learned too many non-creative habits and
wanted to get back into the creative
habits and I became an entrepreneur the
first two years was hell and I made it
in my life change I want to inspire and
encourage as many people to be
entrepreneurs possibly because that's a
purpose so that gives me creativity and
the last one is an uneasiness about the
status quo you are uneasy about status
quo you're uneasy about being content
you're uneasy about how things are and
you want more you you want to get it
better you want to make things better so
you're you're not comfortable with where
you're at and it's always about figuring
out a ways to get better and that
mindset alone create it gives birth to
creativity where you make things better
so now those are eight things that cause
entrepreneurs to be more creative let me
tell you the good and the bad of
creativity because sometimes people take
this message in a complete different way
the good is what you will cost a figure
out ways to solve problems which is
great your concept figure out ways to
process issues which is great your
constant figure out ways to do things
better which is great you'll give birth
to other people that are working around
you who are always thinking about
figuring out ways to make things better
as well because one the fastest way to
become creative is to be around creative
minds and you become creative one of the
fastest way to become non creative is to
be around a bunch of non creative people
and you become non creative right so the
good is you're going to solve problems
in a more Swift Swift way right swiftly
but the problem is this here's the bad
the bat is let's just say you set up a
system in your business that's working
and you keep changing that system
because you're so creative so you're
getting bored so you keep changing
changing changing you're not given an
opportunity for you to you know co-opted
and create momentum let me explain the
sports standpoint so you know this Steph
Curry's shot has been the same for many
many years he's not going to change that
shot that shot works but his creativity
of dribbling of going around and
figuring out ways to go through screen
up that then you can be creative on the
approach but the system is working why
change it the system is producing
results if you do have a system that's
working as producing results and you
know based on how other people are
producing results with that don't change
that part of it every time you do you
lose momentum every single time I've
seen entrepreneurs that go boom boom I
said what happened to you what we
decided to do this why did you do it
when it was already working for you well
you know just kind of thought we can
make it better no you can you can change
up
approach you can change cultures
decision-making challenges overcome but
not necessarily what is working so
sometimes the bad part of creativity is
is also could backfire on you so people
may ask and say well Pat how do I become
more creative right I want to know how
to become more creative let's talk about
that now
one think about the most creative minds
you know make a list of them think about
the most creative minds you know think
about them and they got to be positive
I'm not talk about the most creative
mind it's a drug-dealer that's one very
good and let me go hang out with I'm not
talking about that but think about the
most creative minds you know who are an
entrepreneur or maybe somebody that's
always been good at finding
unconventional ways of solving issues
let's just say and every time you talk
to me a challenge you're thinking about
oh wow a minute I never thought about it
this way be around that person and ask
them questions and process issues with
them so you'll know how they go Thing
Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing
Thing Thing
oh that's their process on how they saw
then ask another one think think think
think think think think
oh I never go that way I go this way
that's strange that's amazing now I get
it right another thing you can do to
become more creative it's just it we're
curious about life really just be
curious about life curious about your
health curious about your body curious
about business curious about solving
problems curious about everything and
that allows you to figure out ways to
solve issues energy you need to have a
lot of energy because creative people
are definitely typically very energized
they have a lot of energy for themselves
to be able to solve issues themselves
next one is inspired figure out a way to
get inspired if you inspire a lot of
things will happen for you and then ask
more questions what I like to do a lot
is this I like to bring the group of
people together and I'll sit down
generally three to five people as all it
takes and I'll put a problem on the wall
and I said guys how can we do this
better and I'll let them say it and
we'll go through what about if we do
this how can we make this better what
about if this happens what about if that
happens what about if this happens what
about if that happens and by purely
processing that issue together what's
taking place is not necessarily us
trying to solve this thing
what's taking places we're getting
better at developing our creative mind
so hopefully you and I are going from
being a 2% on our creativity test to 10%
to 15% to 17% to 20%
relearning our creative habits that we
once had for many many years to go many
many years ago and we've had it and
we're learning how to do that again so
pick any topic you know for me the
strangest thing could be how can we make
the voting system better voting system
what does that have to do with business
nothing we're just talking how can make
the voting system better hey what do you
think about what that person said about
business the other day do you agree with
them hey what do you think about what
Elon Musk said do you agree with what
Mark Hughes with Mark Cuban so do you
agree with them I don't tell me why
because this why do you think he said
that then you know Mark Cuban said
you're a if you borrow money from
people to start a business is Mark Cuban
wrong is you right why is he wrong
why is he right what if you do what if
you don't can somebody to attend
somebody not do it and you're just going
deep because you go and never thought
about that that's interesting you know
yeah that's some so-so man I never
that's pretty interesting okay what can
we do if we were to go on a camping trip
where would you want to go to how would
you set it up how would you get to the
top what would you do with this hey if
you and I were working a Twitter right
now
Twitter's going through this problem
right now would they don't know how to
make money with their subscribership how
would you fix the problem with Twitter
what would you do with that how would
you make money with that what would you
do right now if you were hired at
Twitter to be the operations guys to
show them how to make money what would
you approach me with that hey if you
were working right now with a company
like Yahoo that's lost its sizzle that
only has one way of making money how
would you make Yahoo work what do you
think about the fact that Time magazine
wants to buy Yahoo
why would Time magazine buy Yahoo what's
the purpose of Time magazine buying
Yahoo would you buy Yahoo would you be a
Yahoo if you bought yeah what is Yahoo
why are we buying Yahoo would you spend
the money to buy yeah how what kind of
property made goodness like oh man did
you know that Yahoo made money doing
this did you know that when did you know
that did you know that this person made
money doing this and you're just going
hey what happened with oil what causes
oil to drop what do you think so what
would happen if oil went to $10 a barrel
what would happen to the middle-east
what would happen to this these are all
questions you're thinking that's
creating and it's giving birth to your
creative mind then you take those same
abilities on how you're processing into
your business then you start solving big
problems and small problems in your
business as if it's nothing because your
creative mind has become incredible at
processing issues this also helps you in
your personal life in your financial
life and your help if you apply this
creative thinking so my challenge to you
is figure out a way how to tap into your
creativity and by the way if you want to
link to this article on george lands
creativity test Illya why don't we put a
link on the bottom as well
on george lands creativity test i highly
encourage you to read this article it's
very very interesting and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel value tamo
please do so and if you haven't visited
our website be sure to visit patrick-man
david.com take everybody bye bye